there is a lot going on when you have to
transform into Hellboy so I'm curious
between the makeup effects and the
costume is there one single piece of the
whole getup that you really had a hard
time getting used to a couple yeah the
tail is very difficult to get used to
because I'm used to sitting in chairs
between takes and you can't do that when
you have a tail like you tail gets in
the way of everything so you I just hit
on an Apple box
I would always hit it off things would
always bump into it and the other thing
that was really hard was like when I
become the Beast of the apocalypse he
has really big horns and I had to wear a
special cap that would they'd have to
tighten on my head very because the
horns would have to move in a certain
way and so they'd have to tighten this
thing really dramatically and I would
get really gnarly headaches so that was
like not pleasant - but those were like
yeah those were terrible the other stuff
like while it seems horrible on the
surface like I actually kind of got
really into and I started to like you
know like really enjoy you wear it one
thing I was reading in the press notes
that caught my eye that I think you said
or you said about Mila is that she let
you stay in your intense weird place so
I got curious what is that intense weird
place is specific to Hellboy or is it
with every role look I get like you know
what I do I mean I I here's my my thing
is like I feel like at our essence what
we are as storytellers and in terms as
Acting businesses we are in service of
an audience and of fans like and and I
truly am willing to go to any lengths of
being a weirdo or being busted up or
whatever to create a beautiful product
and sometimes those places get weird
like because I have to play an angry you
know demon who's conflicted and all this
stuff there are some days where I just
you know I
get socially very awkward and very
strange and you know wind up kind of
sometimes even like getting angry it's
stuff like that and I mean I try not to
do it with other people I try to stay
isolated but you know Mila and I will
around each other a lot and and I think
one day I was just doing something and
and she was just like I was like I'm
sorry sighs she was like no no he's like
good you're doing anything but she was
so sweet and supportive and I was like
you know she's just such an like she's
such a great so smart and such a great
artist herself that she understands
creative process in that way and it was
it was liberating wonderful yeah that
doesn't surprise me one bit yeah I was
also wondering if you could paint a
picture for us in terms of the troll
fight 1er because I imagine there's some
interesting cuts that were it looked
very convincing to me so what is that
like for you to walk through on set I
mean you're not actually hitting me five
football fields in the air like that
down do another tree but it's a funny it
was kind of an amazing sequence that
they put together and you know a lot of
it does involve these funny little cuts
and for me it was a lot of like there
was one day in a Coliseum with a green
screen all around but with grass and
trees and turf and like where I was just
like running and sliding and flipping
and doing all this stuff and they kind
of explained to me certain sections of
the sequence and then we would do it but
yeah it was it's a very weird you know
piecemeal day but I'm very happy I love
sequences like that I think they're so
interesting and fun it looked really
good too to wrap up I can tell that you
really care about the fan base here but
you're someone who has been part of a
number of major film and TV fan bases at
this point so what is it about the
Hellboy fan in particular that makes
them stand out I think they're like like
I put this like like diehard weirdos
like in a way that I love like a lot of
them seem to be really like into like
metal and different things like that and
like you know like I met some people
like Marilyn Manson's like a big Hellboy
and like you know there's like some
really cool there's a really cool
Hellboy subculture like the people that
have the tattoos and the whole thing and
it's you know it's these like I mean
it's what I identify with too is why I
love the character so much is like he's
an outcast and I think that people that
love him feel a bit like they're
outcasts and and and and so yeah they're
like you know they're like real nerd
weirdos I'm like I I like